go go go go go this season on Darcy and
Stacy
I rebuke any energy any negativity
Shake It Off what we're going to do
today is the O shot
to improve sexual pleasure nice and
relaxed
[Music]
wow gorgeous I feel like a bride my
first wedding was a quarantine wedding
so this time around I want our wedding
to be like a fairy tale
wedding cakes you can go nine ten eleven
thousand dollars I don't know so much
money
[Music]
time's ticking and she wants a nice
wedding and costs money you gotta get a
job he needs to start contributing if he
doesn't help out I don't know where that
leaves us
do you understand you're gonna sabotage
our wedding oh God I just are you
understand how you speak English
who are you true I see you pleasure I
decided to go to a Matchmaker we can
definitely introduce you to high quality
people okay I'm looking forward to
meeting these amazing men never been in
a Lamborghini before so you have to be a
real man driving this kind of car
different types different ages they have
nice eyes bless you thank you so much
bless you as well but at the same time
it's a little scary because this is my
heart that I'm putting on the line you
are going to get me in trouble here holy
cow sounds okay to break my rule with
you but I have to face my fears get back
up on that horse I freaking ride it
hey I'm 10 minutes from my report I'm
coming in Miami I am not have nothing
friends thank God my best friend's
coming
there's the ax Georgia
it's good to have him big problem
how dare you I know why you came this
this
is not okay with this he still was
innocent aren't you you're nasty I don't
care
I want nothing to do with you this is
the worst fight Darcy and I have ever
had and I'm not sure what it's gonna
take to move past this I need Darcy
she's my other half
thank you
[Music]